i'm laura sky and this is build your
squad I'm here with bleacher report I'm
here to build my all-time NFL squad but
um I work at ice my do you know the goat
decade two decades in in NFL done
unbelievable stuff so you got to go with
Tom from there you go with Randy because
it's Randy you don't tell me any time
you ever caught the ball you didn't say
Randy Randy you know from there you got
to go with Edie and if I know those
safeties that you want on your squad you
know he's gonna make a big play there's
through the eyes of me breathe it's
freaking amazing so you got to go with
it from there
where he go gotta go was drunk cuz ain't
nobody like him what he did in the year
he played was unbelievable he did
incredible stuff so you've got to put
him on the field especially when you got
and brought Randy and Tom he knows
what's gonna happen from the last one I
people don't understand you have to go
what in the biggest pipemakers got his
jersey retired with two different
interval teams as you like ain't much to
say that you don't know about them the
man had a hump move that was
unbelievable I was dominated with two
different organizations like I said he
got his number retired two different
organizations is one people will be a
key factor to you you dynasty right now
so with all these only five people right
now if you ain't one of multiple
championships
that's on coaching and I'm playing
you'll need running back I got Randy I
got drunk and I gotta read you hey you
told air to go run the ball bet you'll
go around the ball now the type of
person he is so that's all you need
right is what you need lock those are we
got to go two decades
Tom Brady done unbelievable stuff in the
league we got Randy Moss anybody going
to get Randy we know that we got Eddie
Reed he's gonna control the whole
defense make sure he does what he needs
to do to make sure the team win you got
a grump okay nobody argue about
what he's able to do on the field it's
unbelievable how talented that man is
you gotta read you white one of the most
dominant defensive ends in NFL history
got a number retired in two different
organizations there's nobody out there
that'd be a better fit for this dynasty
I said a ditch we'll be in I want to
pick nobody else but this group of men
I'm Laura sky and that was build your
squad